this Sunday HBO is debuting its first
ever teen drama and it's called euphoria
and a lot of ads for euphoria here's
what's really grabbing people's
attention the second episode of euphoria
will contain a scene that includes this
is what there's telling everyone at
least thirty penises yes yes that's how
they're promoting the show it's pretty
crazy but even crazier is they've really
this promotion for this new HBO show you
phoria has really taken that and gone
with it check it out HBO has always
delivered programming that's truly
original and boundary-pushing
and in our first teen drama we go all
the way to the edge exploring identity
addiction depression and searching do
you want to guess how many penises there
are in a single episode of euphoria
just try it head on - you got to do way
more than that for no you're not you're
not even close no we've got more Franks
and beans than opposed to July barbecue
we got wall-to-wall that's involved I
don't know 16 16 16 16 listen gentlemen
I'm not gonna bid on how many penises
there are we've got showers growers
leaders dangerous dealers plumpers
pinkies pokers baby arms and hairpin
Turner's it's a force core of Thor skin
here's the cash showing up for work
knock knock who's there
drink doors
22 no 23 no 24 25 Lamar come on euphoria
the only teen drama with HBO's dirty
penis guarantee sir 30 dicks sir
PT's changing